now for reaction by Skype are the affer
mentioned diamond and silk it's great to
see you ladies how you doing oh we're
doing wonderful we hope you're doing
well
yes nice to see you that nice to see you
alright let's start with you
diamond face book and diamond and silk
you guys have had an interesting
relationship over the past several weeks
or even months given the fact that you
discovered that your messages were
suddenly not getting out to your
followers and I know Facebook has had a
response to this but first just tell us
what happened and how you noticed it
well back in September of 2017 we
noticed one day that all of our
engagement had stopped mm-hmm
so we reached out to Facebook
continuously and they kept giving us the
runaround nothing is wrong with your
page there's nothing wrong with it well
well we don't know and we got to reach
back out to our team it was just a back
and forth back and forth and then
finally the straw was the other day when
they wrote and they said that they deem
our content and our brand unsafe to the
community that's right we are the brand
we the brand-new
our chick says down with politics that
that loves our president that loves our
country you know we the brand we the
women that's behind all of this here
right here so what you saying is where
you say that you deem us unsafe to the
community what you said is that we are
we are uncertain who our community is
that that's what you're saying
I mean I don't get that it's offensive
it's appalling I look at this as
discrimination I look at this as freedom
of speech what about our freedom of
speech is a censorship
you shouldn't repeat our voices silk
isn't it the case that the reason I mean
we all know the reason that Facebook
didn't want your posts to reach your
followers is because you're black you're
conservative your support Trump and you
tell it like it is and you call it as
you see it that's offensive to the left
because they want to silence people like
you both you
diamond and silk doesn't matter if it
was just silk or diamond or diamond and
silk they do not want you to reach
people I'm sorry but and I'm gonna say
it until I'm blue in the face they are
afraid of both of you they don't want
your views out we are what you call a
double threat they do not want that
because we do not fit their status quo
or their narrative you know with us
being black people you know their use of
Democrats are so used to black people
being on what we call the Democrat
plantation you supposed to play by our
rules he's not supposed to have much so
that you can depend on the government
and we'll give you what we want you to
have so that we can control you but
diamond is silk we can think for
ourselves right we have our own mind we
don't listen to those negative
narratives that they trying to spin over
there on the Left we can that we have
our own eyes eight of them to see for
ourselves what's really going on behind
the scenes we see the corruption that's
going on in Washington and we didn't
like it that's why we voted for Donald
Trump who is known the president they
try to deem us as dumb as ignorant and
that's uneducated oh honey we're very
smart we see right through all of their
BS that's right let me read what
Facebook originally said on April 5th
the policy team has come to the
conclusion that your content and your
brand has been determined unsafe to the
community okay again I don't know what
community they're talking about or how
it's unsafe neither D but either of you
but now because of all the pressure I
Drudge had this up all day long you guys
have mobilized all your followers my
followers were mobilized and our viewers
last week as well and Facebook said this
we have communicated directly with
diamond and silk about this issue the
message they receive last week wasn't
accurate and not reflective of the way
we communicate with our community and
the people who run pages on our platform
we have provided them with more
information about our policies and the
tools that are applicable to their page
and look forward to the opportunity to
speak with them that according to a
facebook spokesperson ladies I don't
know what that gibberish is but
I'm not I'm not all that convinced
diamond take it away what the heck does
that we haven't spoken to face they've
never communicated to us the last
communication that we got was they
deemed our us unsafe for the community
they have not reached out to us they
have not communicated to us and so you
just sound like a white light on like
these little white lies if you gonna
tell it tell the truth or go somewhere
to sit down that's right they did not
communicate with us but that weird they
say they did hey so could they said we
have communicated with diamond and silk
about this issue they did not I have not
conversating we've been in the air all
day flying back from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania that's right here to North
Carolina so we could be on the show
tonight nobody has communicated with
diamond and silk so that is a lot of
things putting out that's a lot and by
the way we have a list of groups
left-wing groups that have not been
deemed unacceptable antifa
those lovely people The Young Turks
never profane Planned Parenthood no
violence there occupy Democrats have no
idea what it is the political resistance
against Donald Trump all of those groups
are okay according to Facebook all right
so you are more of a threat to the
community than an Tifa are you kidding
me I mean Zuckerberg better be asked
questions about this tomorrow that's all
I can say
you know billionaire boys club you
better be asked questions about diamond
and silk yes it's embarrassing insulting
and it's defamation of our characters
right because we're not a danger to
society we ain't never killed nobody we
don't do no drugs we're not out in the
streets that's right America no you're
dangerous because you challenged the
liberal orthodoxy that if you're not a
Trump hater and you in if you're an
african-american then then there's got
to be something wrong with you I mean
they did it too
they do it to Tom's soul they do it to
Walter Williams they've done it to
Clarence Thomas anyone who is black who
doesn't know the liberal line they want
to demonize and marginalize and they've
they're trying to do it to you through
these mega corporations and I'm telling
you these corporations you know it's not
it's not good business for them it's not
smart ladies do you think this will be
addressed tomorrow
I hope it's address tomorrow yeah and I
hope Zuckerberg tells the truth that
somehow you put these algorithms in
place - silent conservative voice that's
right let them know how you made a
mistake and how you plan to correct them
not only are our platform but every
conservative that you silence you need
to correct that immediately just need to
be a even playing field and I don't care
if you want to say you private but you
open to the public baby I just have to
be fair over each yeah all I can say is
I hung out with you a little bit on
election night and I gotta come hung I
got to come down there and hang out with
you guys you guys put me in a good mood
okay I look I think God for Skype thanks
so much for coming on and we will keep
following this and we have more updates
on this as the show goes on thank you so
much ladies